it's been called their most complex to
her to date and with good reason
Prince William and his wife Kate are on
their first official visit to Pakistan a
country dealing with ever-present
security issues the Duke and Duchess of
Cambridge will also look at Pakistan's
efforts at fighting climate change and
aim to highlight the country as a quote
dynamic aspirational and forward-looking
nation those words from Britain's High
Commissioner to Pakistan
Thomas drew the couple have visited a
school a national park and had a private
lunch with Prime Minister Imran Khan but
it was their arrival in a colourful
tooktook also called an autorickshaw in
the subcontinent that had heads turning
the couple were attending an evening
reception at the Pakistan Monument in
the capital Islamabad and Shah Geelani
from DW Asia has been following the
visit
Shaza why is this visits so important
for Pakistan you know it's been a while
British royalty visit took place in
Pakistan the last time somebody visited
was about 13 years ago and this couple
is young it's glamorous its charismatic
and the visit could not have come at a
better time for Pakistan when the
government faces challenges on the
foreign policy front the economy is
sinking the Prime Minister is becoming
unpopular but this visit helps showcase
the positive side of Pakistan it's
breathtaking beauty the diversity of its
culture and that it has its people
essentially hardworking and decent
people so it's a win-win for both
Britain and Pakistan but aside from that
the Royal coupled themselves appear to
be very popular in Pakistan why is that
well a lot of people relate to this
couple because of their longing for
Princess Diana she visited Pakistan a
couple of times in the 90s the last time
she was there was in 1997 and this
reference came up quite a few times
during this visit
when the Duke was meeting children in
school they said you know we really
loved your mother she was an amazing
woman and he also said you know I was
also fond of her so people have those
memories and I think in pakistan's
collective memory there's that link with
Princess Diana of Prince William and
Kate Middleton so a lot of people see it
in that light and it's part and parcel
of the collective memory of Pakistan and
how they relate to the royal family
Josep Jelani from DW asia thanks very
much for that but there appears to be
another side to this visit and that is
the criticism on social media DW
reporter Michelle Stockman has been
looking at some of their criticism and
joins me now in the studio with more
Michelle welcome what have you found
indeed there has been criticism of this
visit there are some Pakistanis who look
at this as window dressing who look at
it as a way to distract the so-called
masses from some very real problems
Pakistan faces economically socially and
environmentally there's a tweet that we
can bring up here that that reflects on
that sentiment says even in the UK
people have woken up to the fact that
for decades the British media has used
the spectacle of the royal family to
distract from the failures of the
government maybe that's why they decided
to bring their show to a more gullible
audience and then there's another tweet
pointing figures at the legacy of
British colonialism in the region it
says if it weren't for these Royals we
won't have a dumb and fascist army
ruling over us the mess they left behind
to ensure there is no peace ever in the
subcontinent and that tweet ends hashtag
a royal visit Pakistan some very strong
language there in those streets makes me
interesting discussions later but
overwhelmingly the response has been
positive has it not been to this visit
and a lot of it has to do potentially
with the optics and in particular
fashion choices oh yes there is no way
around it beresch when you look at this
visit you have to look at the fashion
and pulling that focus has been Kate and
she has managed to stay true to her own
style and yet Slough
local designers and we're gonna bring up
a tweet here that basically is a love
letter to her and her outfit so far here
she's wearing an array of shalwar kameez
that is the long dress and trouser combo
that is ubiquitous for women across
Pakistan she's wearing blue that's a nod
to Diana the people's princess beloved
in Pakistan and then please note this
green shade it is very it's it's a nod
to the Pakistani flag so she has managed
to stay true to herself and yet she
looks like a very elegant Pakistani
woman going out and about about her
business and then we have to talk about
this moment that we see back here and I
do not know if you can top this in terms
of winning the hearts of the Pakistani
people this is the perfect combination
of Pakistani high fashion and folk
culture and this is a tweet we're gonna
bring up put out by Kensington Palace
and this shows the Prince stepping up
his game he is wearing a traditional
cher hwanhee suit he's escorting the
Duchess in a tuk-tuk painted in the
traditional Pakistani truck art style
it's almost reminiscent of their wedding
day when they were riding around in that
hot red car you know it's kind of like
the Pakistani iteration of that just
just fantastic I mean Wow wouldn't you
want a hobnob with them and I know if I
was in Pakistan invited to a party and I
had a royal budget I would want to wear
something like this I would certainly
love to wear some of that that kind of
[ __ ] worried that the patterns on that
are amazing and that tuk-tuk looking
more like a truck truck if I can call it
that
we shall stock well thanks very much for
coming in and bring that down for us
welcome